Thanks for joining us. I'm Steve Shu and
I'm Corey Washington and we're your
hosts for Manifold. Uh our guest today
is Ted Chang. He is one of my favorite
science fiction writers and also one of
Corey's. His work has won I'm now
reading from his Wikipedia entry which I
hope is accurate. Four Nebula Awards and
four Hugo awards. and his short story,
Story of Your Life, was the basis for
the the film Arrival, which was uh which
appeared in 2016. So, welcome to our
show, Ted.
Thank you very much.
Now, in uh setting up the outline for
the show, Ted and I corresponded a bit
and I had originally proposed all kinds
of sort of standard questions about
writing and literary stuff. And Ted sort
of responded that he gets these
questions all the time, but I think he
doesn't get to talk to a theoretical
physicist and a neuroscientist/
philosopher, which is what Cory is, uh,
that often. And so he wanted to perhaps
focus the discussion more on topics uh,
gerine to those areas. So a lot of the
things we're going to discuss today
actually involve uh, fundamental
concepts in physics and science and also
in philosophy.
That's that's yeah, that's what I'm
hoping for.
Great. And I we're looking forward to it
too because we I at least my opinion is
you're one of the best in the business
in writing about the deep conceptual
side of all these issues and and making
it into entertaining fiction. So let me
start with uh an observation about
something called hard science fiction
which is a kind of subgenre of science
fiction. And the way I often describe
hard science fiction is that it's one in
which they really get into the technical
detail and try to get those details
right. But it's often from more of what
I would call an engineering kind of
focus where they really are interested
in like how does the actual rocket
engine work or the sensor array uh for
the spaceship. And the way I kind of
think about your style is that uh in
your case, what you're really striving
for is a very deep internal scientific
consistency of the ideas that are uh
central to the story. And often times
this internal scientific consistency is
hidden from the casual reader. I think
the casual reader who's not a scientist
wouldn't really even notice that that's
going on. But for an actual scientist
like me, it's very striking because I
read your stories and I just sense that
you've thought through the underlying
assumptions and the underlying science
very very carefully and deeply and so I
never detect as far as I know
inconsistencies in the struct even in
the internal structure of your stories.
So maybe you can comment on this
perception of your fiction.
Well, okay. So the definition of hard
science fiction is something that is
subject to endless debate. people will
argue just add infinitum about uh what
is the proper definition of hard science
fiction. the type of fiction that you're
describing that has a focus on the
engineering side of things on getting
the delta V right for a a vehicle
traveling you know uh between the earth
and the moon or you know the earth and
Mars you know that is that is a a type
of hard science fiction that is what
some people would think of as being true
hard science fiction and and and and I
should say I definitely respect and
admire that type of fiction. I myself, I
am interested in my own writing, I'm
interested more in I guess sort of the
broader theoretical or philosophical
side of things.
And I guess one of the things that I've
said about hard science fiction and
science is that in the same way that
science itself can be understood as
maybe not so much as a as a collection
of facts but as a way of looking at the
universe, a way of approaching the
universe, a way of understanding the
universe because you know the specific
collection of facts that will change
over time but the underlying approach
remains the same. there's a certain
scientific mindset, a worldview uh which
I think is that is perhaps the true
essence of science as in human endeavor.
I think that another way of thinking
about science fiction and hard science
fiction is fiction which you know it may
or may not conform to a specific you
know collection of facts but it embodies
the scientific mindset, the scientific
worldview. It tries to represent
how scientists think about the universe,
how they understand the universe to work
and that is something that I'm
interested in.
And I when you talk about the fact that
you're interested in the philosophical
kind of foundation implications, that's
what really came through very strongly
in your writing. You know, we talk about
particular examples such as, you know, I
when I'm reading Exhale, I'm really
thinking a lot about Cheryl's Chinese
room example, often from the flip side
of it. And I'm seeing your engagement
with issues of free will. I guess I want
to disagree a little bit because your
perspective seems very much a kind of
merging of philosophy and science and I
think is very positive, but I think it's
actually been lost in a lot of modern
science. I've been struck by how non-f
philosophical science has become
especially things like neuroscience
whereas I think many great scientists
many traditional scientists before the
split came really saw these issues as
deeply intertwined and they become more
separated uh in the modern era. So I
guess I I I I guess have your reaction
to the combination of science and
philosophy. Is that at the heart of your
writing? And do you see yourself as
someone engaged in a kind of more I
guess I say more an older more
traditional an older tradition that saw
these two things as with the flip sides
of a given coin.
That's a that's that's an interesting
perspective I guess you know and that
may be a reflection of the fact that you
know I am not actually a working
scientist. So I am not out there in the
trenches on a day-to-day basis. uh so I
have not been subject to perhaps the
intense specialization and narrow focus
uh maybe working scientists have to deal
with. So I can take a maybe broader view
of science than someone who is actually
having to like you know write up grant
applications. So you know in that sense
yes it may be that my my view of science
is a a somewhat older one where science
and scientists are participating in a
kind of tradition of you know to some
extent philosophical inquiry about the
universe that is definitely the sort of
thing that I am most interested in.
Yeah, I I and I can't say how much that
is in the forefront of the minds of
people who are actually working in
science right now.
Yeah, I think to Corey's point, there
are a lot there are large parts of
science in which uh you might call sort
of normal science where you're not
making a revolutionary discovery, but
you're making some incremental progress
like measuring some parameter to more
accuracy or measuring some fact about
some organism. But it doesn't change our
overall kind of philosophical worldview
or the way that we regard nature or our
loca our location in the universe, our
role in nature. But I my sense is the
interesting aspects that you choose to
illuminate in your stories are often
ones which get to the philosophical
heart of what science tells us.
I suppose in some ways if you're going
to tell a story if you're going to write
a story about say journalism to some
extent you could focus on the really
nitty-gritty
details of journalistic practice but I
think it's probably true that you know
if you're going to write a story about
journalists you're also going to have
the story reflect some something about
like
the reasons why journalism matters why
people go into journalism What is the
purpose of journalism?
Which is something which you journalists
may not actually you'll be wrestling
with on a day-to-day basis. On a
day-to-day basis, they're wrestling with
much more mundane nitty-gritty things.
But yeah, if you're telling a story
about journalism, about you know the
pursuit of journalism, then you will
probably try and bring in the broader
themes, the reasons why people go into
journalism in the first place. It is a
perhaps a more, you know, idealized
version, but still reflects a a
fundamental truth about journalism. And
so in the same way that if you're
writing about scientists, you could
write about the day-to-day, you know,
nitty-gritty work of being a scientist
and trying to trying to get your grant
application approved or, you know,
dealing with departmental politics or,
you know, requisitioning equipment and
things like that. All of which are
important parts of the lives of
scientists.
For one thing, you know, I don't I don't
know I don't know a lot about that side
of things. So, I'm not going to write
about that. I'm not the right person to
write about uh that sort of thing. As
someone who is not a working scientist,
I am interested in I guess you know the
ideals of science as a pursuit. What
does the pursuit of
of science represent? What is that
about? Those are the things that I'm
interested in and try to write about.
Let let me mention another aspect of
your style and and hear what you have to
think about what you think about it. I
sort of sense that you have a fully
worked out view of the world in a
particular story that you're writing
about and that you've sort of worked out
the way things work scientifically, the
natural laws and their implications in
that world. And that is why perhaps a
reader like me senses an internal
consistency in the world that you're
creating. One of the people that you're
often compared to Bourhees who also
wrote short stories which also contain
some kind of speculative or imaginative
component. Often times when I read his
stories it's not clear at all to me that
he has fully fleshed out the working
rules of the world that he's sketching
in the story. And so to me that's that's
an important difference between you and
Bores. So can you can you comment a
little bit about your thoughts about the
working out the full internal
consistency of the worlds in which you
set your stories?
I I guess I sort of think that that may
have to do with uh the fact that I came
out of a science fiction tradition
whereas Bourhees did not. Bourhees who
is you know I think undoubtedly a genius
but he did not write for an audience of
science fiction readers. you know he did
not come out of a a tradition of reading
you know sort of genre science fiction.
So his concerns are not exactly those of
science fiction writers or readers. So,
so you know the question of is the is
the universe of the story you know
completely worked out in detail is it
really internally consistent you know I
think you know that's not something
which is of enormous interest to
Bourhees he fleshes things out enough to
you know evoke a universe and you know
as long as the details are are
sufficient to sort of convey the ideas
that he is trying to convey then you
know that's all the story needs. Yeah, I
I agree with that. And it's no fault of
Borhes. I mean, he wasn't, as you say,
trying to do exactly the same kind of
thing that you're doing. But but
sometimes people like even scientists or
mathematicians will point to a Bourhees
short story and say, "See, he really
illustrates the meaning of infinity or
something or recursion in this story."
But I often feel like your stories do a
better job uh of illustrating a specific
concept because of the extra detail and
extra consistency that you impose.
Uh, I'm I'm I'm not I'm not going to
claim that my stories can compare to
Bourhees in any way.
So, I'm glancing over at Steve's notes
here and um he's preparing to ask you
about free will and there are a couple
of stories in your new collection that
touch on free will. So, don't if you
mind if we get a little bit specific
because I'm because I'm really kind of
fascinated by um the science behind
these stories. So in what's expected of
us, you discuss a device called a
predictor uh which uh will flash a
signal about a second or so before a
person makes a decision. And uh as you
flesh out, you really can't do anything
about this signal, right? If you try to
jump the gun, the predictor will get
there a second before you uh perform an
action, make a decision. If you try to
trick it by waiting, it doesn't actually
light up. Now I I I when I'm reading
this I'm thinking about Libbit's
experiments from the from 1983 where he
showed that there is a I think it was an
fMRI signal or um which happens roughly
a second before we make decision. This
had an enormous impact on philosophy
when this result came out because I
think many people uh drew the same
conclusion you did which is and maybe
this is also quite obvious from simple
understanding of conventional physics
that our lives are largely determined
and the appearance or impression we have
of free will is in fact elusory. Your
brain has essentially made a decision
before you've actually become
consciously aware of that. And uh as you
uh play this out, I I first like to get
your reaction to it. Uh was this in fact
were you moved by Libbit's experiments
when you began to think about the story?
Actually, no. I am not that I'm not that
impressed by Libbit's findings. I mean,
they are certainly interesting findings,
but I don't think they say anything
substantive about free will. I think all
they do is uh show that there are there
are certain, you know, there's a certain
type of brain activity that precedes
your conscious, you know, decision-m
but I don't think that that materially
changes anything about the discussion of
free will. All all it says is that
decision-m is a neural process which
doesn't happen in the very moment. It's
something which you know is sort of
built up to. But I think that you know
all the all all the arguments pro or con
free will can still be made irrespective
of libert's results. but isn't one of
the main at least we might not call an
argument for free will but it's the it's
a sense the argument from the feeling
right we feel like we are making these
decisions at a certain moment and that
may not be an actual argument for free
will but probably explains why many of
us think we have it and you don't think
that these results call into question
whether this experience is indicative of
free will given that the signal comes
before you have any conscious experience
of making the decision
you know, it's it's only like a second
that that limit found, you know, that
this this neural activity was happening
before you you actually, you know, may
made a physical action. I don't think
that that is that significant. I think,
you know, our conscious perception of
our decision-m process is not that fine
grained in its temporal resolution. So,
the fact that you felt it happen at 9
seconds past the past the minute and it
was actually happening 8 seconds past
the minute, I I don't think that's a big
deal.
I I think the issue Cory's raising is
that the feeling that you made the
decision at a particular moment that
your conscious brain has of making the
decision or coming to the conclusion
might itself be an illusion. And that
might be illustrated by these
experiments because actually the
decision was made maybe a second before
but you didn't know it. Your conscious
brain didn't know it. And I think that
that's about all you can get from
living.
Yeah, that's kind of what I'm getting
at. But so I'm kind of thinking about
your story, right? Because you're I
think drawing out the consequence that
the predictor effectively gives you this
signal in the outside world, right? In
an LED respon in an LED form. And people
find this incredibly unsettling. uh you
rightly observe.
So let me just for our audience maybe
say something about the story. So it's a
very short story. It's I think it's
beautifully done. It's it's actually my
favorite story of yours, Ted. And um in
the story someone is given a bracelet
and the when the light flashes it
indicates that you'll then push the
button on the bracelet. Is it what's the
lag? 3 seconds or some number of seconds
later? Right. There are sort of two ways
you could think about it. Your
interpretation, Corey, is one that I
didn't really think of, which is that
perhaps the bracelet is monitoring your
brain and it knows you've made a
decision and then it flashes to show the
decision has been made and then since
you made the decision, then you push the
button. I had always interpreted I think
which is the way that Cory des Ted
describes it in the story is that there
is what we physicists would call a
closed timelike curve which connects uh
the bracelet at one time to the bracelet
at an earlier time. And so what happens
is when you press the button, it sends a
message backwards in time which causes
in the past the light to go off. And so
the light having gone off means that the
message was sent which means that you
did in fact push the button 3 seconds
later. And so it's a to me an amazing
illustration like with all the right
psychological
implications and things like that of
what it would be like for a human to
interact with a closed timelike curve.
And it's brilliant also because the the
the time difference between the the
sending of the message and the light
going off is short enough that it has
kind of a very strong psychological
impact.
Well, yes, Steve's Steve's reading of
the story is is correct because I I I I
think the story makes it clear that it
is not monitoring any any neural
behavior, any neural phenomena. It's a
circuit with a negative time delay. So,
it is a closed timelike curve on on a
logic board. It's a it's a closed
timelike curve on a logic board. So,
yes, it is sending a signal back in
time. And because of that, it's not
something that you can trick by say
removing it from a person. You like you
can if you if you try and build a device
something use like using one of those
those drinking bird death toys. If you
try and build something like that that
will hit the button, you will not be
able to trick the device because it is
precisely the fact that the button gets
pushed that sends the signal back in
time and causes the the LED to to light
up.
So yeah, it is is not a version of
Libbit's experiment. It is something
which is is more a demonstration of
something that relativistic physics
discusses.
Yeah. And I think one of our topics, the
next topic has to do with varieties of
time travel. And a certain variety of
time travel is illustrated in this
story. And so I want to get to that in a
second. But before we get to that, I
want to continue talking about free will
a little bit. And so the physicist view
of free will is the following. So in
physics we at least uh in classical
physics and this is modified a little
bit in quantum mechanics but in
classical physics the idea is if you
know the positions and the velocities of
all the molecules at time t equals z you
can perfectly predict the positions and
velocities of those um molecules or
atoms whatever they are particles at
some later time say t equals 1 second
in conventional physics
in conventional physics and that was a
dream of the early physicists that this
could be true and early mechanics and
studies of motion seem to indicate that
actually the equations were simple
enough that you could they were totally
deterministic. The state of the system
at tals 0 totally determines the state
of the system at t= 1 t=2. Now if that's
true then the question arose what room
is there for free will. So in other
words, if the state of the entire
universe were to be known at time t
equals z, then we know the state at all
future times because we can just follow
the equations forward. And then the
argument would go, the only thing that
could be left is the illusion of free
will. So you don't know that the
decision you will make about what to
have for lunch was already determined by
the state of your stomach and your
glands and the picture of the chicken
that you were shown on TV that morning.
but it was actually determined and you
have only the illusion of making a
choice but the choice was determined.
So I think that's the common sense
interpretation but you know philosophers
often argue for things they're not
common sensical and so there's a huge
literature on what's called
compatibilism
right and I I think Ted is a fan perhaps
of conatibilism. Am I right about that
Ted?
Yes. Yes I am.
So I've always had trouble understanding
what people mean when they say
compatibilism. So I think you want
you're saying that compatibilism is not
the same thing as observing that we have
merely the illusion of free will. Is
that
Yes. I think I mean I'm not an expert in
this type of metaphysics but as far as I
know people really want to say that
there's can be a robust concept of free
will that's fully consistent with a
deterministic universe. And again I'm a
very far removed from this literature
but as far as I understand that's what
kind of robust philosophical
compatibilism holds. It's not just an
illusion of free will. It's not just an
epipenomenon. It's actually something
that's somehow consistent with fully
deterministic universe. Ted, where in
the perspective of compatibilism does
your position lie?
I am a compatibilist. So, I guess my my
stance is largely uh based on I guess
Daniel Dennett's arguments in favor of
compatibilism.
So I guess the way I would phrase it is
that what is it that you want from free
will that that you are not getting. You
know if you try and nail down what it is
that people want from free will what
they you know when they when they use
that phrase what do they want from that
and what is it that they're not getting.
It seems to me that uh like some naively
people want the they want the future to
be completely unknown in that that there
is no there is no future. So there's a
future where they choose option A and
there's a future where they choose
option B and they are both
potentialities and only when they make
that decision does one actually obtain
and the other one ceases to to be a
possibility.
The way I I think about it is that so
they're they're imagining you know that
there are these sort of two scenarios in
the scenario where they choose option A
and the scenario where they choose
option B the entire history of the
universe
every you know the position and velocity
of every atom was exactly the same up
until the moment that they made their
decision and in one case they made they
chose option A and then the other case
they chose option B
and if that's what they want from free
will. Like, yeah, I I don't think that's
a really that's that's something that is
something meaningful. That's not
something that they actually want
because that that's that scenario means
that
their choice of option A or option B
depended on absolutely nothing that
happened in the entire history of the
universe prior to that point. It cannot
have depended on it because they're
exactly the same in both cases.
So that that that means choosing option
A and option B was essentially a kind of
a quantum coin flip.
And I don't think that's what people
actually want. That's that's that's no
kind of decision at all.
What if someone says my my deep
suspicion people who really want free
will are kind of dualists. They think
there's another there's a parallel level
to the universe which is not physically
determined
and their choice comes from this other
layer of kind of consciousness mind and
that can intervene in the physical world
and drop down and that's what has the
cause that's what causes the universe to
go towards option A or option B. It's
that causation of mind or consciousness
that constitutes free will and is not
part of the previous physical structure
of the universe.
Yes, they they are looking for a kind of
dualism even if they might not express
it that way. They uh are looking for a
kind of immaterial soul although again I
think most of them would rather not
phrase it that way. Then there's a
question of like how does this
immaterial soul
how does it work? Not and I don't mean
like in a detailed physical sense
because it's it's obviously non-physical
but when we think about what we want
from free will you know we want to I
think to some extent we want to
deserve credit for the good decisions we
make and deserve the blame for the bad
decisions we make and some of that will
arise out of our process of deliberation
the factors that go into our process of
deliberation
are everything that we have experienced
in our life.
So those are all physical things.
Everything that that happened to your in
your life those were all physical
things. So the process of deliberation
by which you sort of are roughly
speaking taking all the experiences of
your life as inputs
and then you know one of the outputs is
your decision between option A and
option B. That is something which I
believe that is entirely compatible with
a materialist physicalist uh universe.
And I think a materialist physicalist
universe
provides you with what you want because
your your decision is the result of your
life experience being processed through
your cognition.
That is what you want from free will.
And I think that is what compatibilism
what a what a materialist universe
actually gives you. So based on that
definition of compatibilism, I don't
object to it. But I I would assert that
to me it sounds very similar to the
notion that we have the illusion of free
will, but nevertheless may live in a
deterministic universe.
See, I guess I don't know why it's an
illusion versus the reality.
Yeah. So that comes down to defining
what it Yeah. what one means by free
will. Of course, I I just think that
deeply embedded in the concept of free
will is the fact that I can sit here and
regardless of my past history,
regardless the entire state of every
atom in the universe, by willing
something, I can change the course.
Yes. So,
of my life and thus everything else. So,
so, so that is a decent definition of
free will, the one that you just gave.
And then if that's your definition, then
I say you only have the illusion of that
kind of free will. It's an illusion. You
don't actually have that kind of free
will.
I'm I'm generally sympathetic to
determinism, but I' I'd step back and
say, well, but this feeling is so
strong and it's so hard to predict
powerful illusion.
Okay. But so hard to predict the course
of where I'm going to move my hand given
our current physics. Nothing in our
current physics is going to be able to
allow you now or for the foreseeable
future.
In practice, you're right. Uh the other
way to view it is that your
consciousness, your sense of self is
this ephemeral, fragile little bubble
floating on the surface of this deep
ocean. And of course, it doesn't know
where you're going to move your hand.
It's possible, but there's a strong
feeling that it's there. The question
is, do you want to override this feel?
Do you want to allow our current
scientific understanding of the world,
which we all know is incomplete? This
whole list of things we don't understand
about nature. We don't understand dark
matter. We don't understand the origin
of the universe. All these things we
don't understand this incomplete picture
of nature can allow this to override
this incredibly strong feeling.
So you have this intuition which maybe
evolutionary there evolution required
you to have of making decisions and free
will and uh our science is complete and
in fact we may eventually discover a
small ethereal tether which goes out the
back of your head into this parallel
universe where somehow there are not
causes for outcomes. Uh and the decision
is really made there. that that's what
you're kind of groping for with this
dualist. I
I'd say or I'd say that our current
science seems to have two basic
paradigms. One is pure determinism and
the other is stochastics of quantum
mechanics. Right? Those seem to be the
alternatives. It's either purely
determined or it's random in some kind
of distribution. And I think what free
wants wants to say there's something in
between those two poles. Uh and we may
not quite understand how you get there,
but like the world's not purely random.
It's not really deterministic and we
don't quite know how that's going to
become compatible with our current
physics.
Yeah.
I I think I think I agree with what
you're saying. Let's uh because we're we
don't have that much time. Let's go on
to our next topic which is varieties of
time travel. And so in the story that we
just discussed, we encountered one
variety of time travel. for lack of a
better word, I'll call that the
consistent
one-time
uh version of the structure of of of
time. So, in other words, what you did
when you push the button and sent the
signal back in time to cause the LED to
go off, no matter what uh transpires
subsequent to the light going off, it
must be something which is consistent
with the fact that you then later push
the button. And one of my former PhD
students is a huge afficionardo of this
kind of science fiction. He's always
searching for really complex sci-fi
stories and movies where they've
perfectly realized this kind of universe
and all the facts are consistent but
there's only one timeline and it was
unavo all the events that happened were
essentially unavoidable. Uh this goes
back to free will a little bit.
Unavoidable on that timeline. So I think
he claims 12 Monkeys. There's a science
fiction movie called 12 Monkeys. Yeah,
it's a Brad Pitt movie. Is that right?
Yes. Yes. And he claims that that's a
very well-realized version of this kind
of structure of time.
And uh let maybe we can ask Ted how he
feels about it and whether he's ever
written stories realizing another
version of time travel. Maybe time
travel between different parallel
universes.
Well, I I agree that 12 Monkeys is is a
movie that poses a single fixed
timeline, and I think 12 Monkeys does a
pretty good job of it. Also, as another
example, the first Terminator film is an
example of this. The second Terminator
film is not, but the first Terminator
film does posit a um a fixed timeline.
And you know, this is something that I'm
interested in. And you know, there's a
sense in which what's expected of us
falls into this category. Also, the
story uh The Merchant and the Alchemist
Gate falls in this category. There's
even a sense in which for my first
collection, a story of your life falls
in this category.
As for a time travel story which posits
alternate or parallel timelines,
I I think the closest I come to that is
the final story in the new collection
which is called Anxiety is the dizziness
of freedom.
Well, it's it's basically sort of the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics. So, it's not exactly the it's
not exactly the branching timelines
created by time travelers which we
sometimes see in time travel stories,
but it is similar to it in in some ways.
I really like the story The Merchant in
the Alchemist Gate. In that story,
you're dealing with a deterministic
past. You know, you can't change things,
so you're highly constrained.
Yes, it is constraining. My inspiration
in large part came from hearing Kip
Thorne talk about how one could actually
construct a closed timelike curve. And
Kip Thorne had, you know, he actually
set up a a thought experiment involving
billiard balls where, you know, he tried
to imagine could a billyard ball knock
itself off course and create sort of the
billiard ball version of the grandfather
paradox.
And when he, you know, solved those
equations, he said, "No, you can't.
There's only a consistent timeline
possible." I was interested in trying to
imagine what that might be like in human
dramatic terms.
And stories in which there's a fixed
timeline, stories in which it is
impossible to change the past, like 12
Monkeys, they are usually downbeat
stories. There's a, you know, there's
definitely a tradition of this in
science fiction and they're usually kind
of depressing. They they end on a note
of despair. 12 Monkeys certainly does
and arguably Terminator does as well.
And so what I was trying to do is to see
it was possible to write a story about a
single fixed timeline
which didn't end on a downbeat note.
And so that was really sort of the
animating impulse for Merchant and the
Alchemist Gate. I
I think in a universe where that kind of
time travel is possible, one would be
very happy because historians could
actually do their job. They could
actually go back and make sure they
really understood what happened in the
past. Otherwise, kind of impossible to
do that. Just to comment on the Kip
Thorne uh thought experiment. So Kip
Thorne for the movie I think for for for
the maybe for the book that Carl Sean
wrote contact wanted to design a kind of
realistic mechanism for interstellar
travel. And so he came up with the idea
of building a wormhole and pulling uh
the ends in a certain way so that the
two ends ended up at different times.
And one of the things that I've actually
done research on is it turns out in
order to stabilize a wormhole in general
relativity, so a wormhole is a very
special thing in spacetime. It turns out
you need matter with a very unusual
equation of state with a very very
unusual properties. And there's an open
question as to whether such materials
could ever exist in the universe. And
now there's very strong evidence uh from
theoretical calculations that such
matter cannot be stable. It cannot
actually exist. And so it may be that
this particular way of making a time
machine is not possible. Now when he was
looking at this, this was not known. And
so he was interested in questions of
whether the laws of physics given the
existence of this kind of closed
timelike curve, would the laws of
physics otherwise conspire to keep
things consistent so that the the
billyard ball could not go back in time
and knock itself out of the way before
it entered the wormhole. And so that
that's the I guess the motivation
originally for TED
Kip Thorne was um he was author with
Wheeler with this very large textbook
gravitation. Yes. Which I remember
reading. Yes.
As an undergraduate and it was kind of a
the bible of general relativity for
quite a while.
Yes.
I had no idea he was behind involved in
in contact.
Yeah. It was actually because of science
fiction that he kind of got pushed but
because Carl Sean was writing a science
fiction novel that he asked Kip about
this question and that pushed Kip's
research direction in in that way. So um
it's quite interesting in in a way it's
a little bit because I worked on this I
know it's a little bit disreputable in
physics like people are asking you why
are you working on this problem and or
stability in my case like stability of
matter that violates the null energy
condition that was like something I
worked on for a while and I would just
say well it's intrinsically interesting
question whether matter like this can
exist and it has these implications for
time travel but I think most physicists
thought Steve you should go and think
about the top quark instead or something
they thought it was just too far out.
Yeah. Just the motivation. I thought it
was very strange because as a physicist
like why did we get into physics? We got
into physics to actually understand
things like this like do the laws of
physics as we currently understand them
allow for the construction of a time
machine or a closed timelike curve and
uh so it seems like the most important
thing that you should be thinking about
as a physicist but you know how things
work in science. You know the NSF
doesn't give the grant for that. that
NSF gives a grant for trying to make a
slightly better superconductor or a
slightly stiffer, you know,
electromagnet or something like that.
So, it becomes a kind of a unusual
activity. It seems to me there's a
progression throughout the book and when
you get to the last story, you bring
these two topics together, the
deterministic timeline and also free
will. Um, when you get to the the story
about anxiety,
anxiety is the dizziness of freedom.
Yeah. And was that was that explicit
motivation? Because people in this story
agonize
about their ability to affect the
future. Often when they see when their
their paraself has done better than they
have, they wonder if they've done
something wrong and they're often
reminded that you actually it's nothing
they did that resulted in their in their
current lives being good or bad. But at
the same time there's a so emphasis on
the fact that you there is determinism.
uh there may not be free will and kind
of playing out the consequence of this
in this story. I thought was very
interesting because one of the central
assumptions the story is that we can be
envious of ourselves which I thought was
fascinating because you normally we
think of as something involving other
people but of course if they're parallel
universes you have all these kind of
psychological reactions and a lot of the
story is built around this really human
reaction to seeing yourself as something
other existing in this parallel
universe. I never really come across
that concept before and I'm wondering
had you before or is this something you
thought about when you first developed
this what our reaction would be to
ourselves?
It certainly has come up in science
fiction before of meeting your parallel
self not in the context of written
science fiction but there have been some
some movies which address this question.
There's a movie called um I think it's
called The Family Man starring Nicholas
Cage in which he gets a chance to see
what his life would have been like had
he made it a decision many years ago
differently. There was a an Australian
film called Me, Myself, I starring
Rachel Griffith in which she also gets
to see what her life would have been
like had she made a different choice. I
think you know it's a very human
question about wondering did I make the
right choice? Would my life have gone
better if I had done something
differently in the past? And if you
could actually see it, then I think it
would be people would be very prone to
envy because I think people are prone to
envy just because they just I think
that's a natural human tendency. And so
I think if you could actually see the
life that you might have lived, I think
people probably would often be envious
of that. So maybe you know this movie,
it used to be the most famous Christmas
movie, It's a Wonderful Life with Jimmy
Stewart. And I think he spends the whole
time contempl
he gets to see what the world would have
been like if he had died or if he had
done something differently and it's a
much worse world. So he he then
appreciates all the contributions he had
made to the world with the choices that
he made. I'm surprised at your reaction
to this, Corey, because as somebody who
almost left physics, for example, to go
work at a hedge fund, I constantly
think, man, what would my life be like
if I had gone off and done that? And
have given all the things you've done in
your life, I'm surprised you don't want
your
No, I don't have it. I have to say this
story created enormous anxiety in me.
It's actually combined with another
story, your lifelog because the lifelog
story shows you can actually look back
and see very objectively at least mean
in some sense objectively from a certain
perspective the mistakes you've made. By
the way, this is the story which posits
that people could have perfect memory
and then look back at all the events in
their lives with perfect clarity. Is
that
Yeah, exactly. What's it's funny this is
a slight digression but what struck me
about your collection is you explore
different kinds of technologies and some
are fairly far out like the prism which
may never happen may happen thousands of
years some are on the verge of happening
right now and I think people are already
life logging their kids and I have
really no doubt that in a decade or two
life logging will be a very very common
phenomenon so all the implications that
come from that story are things we're
have to grapple with you'll be able to
look back and see the things that you
did and often resolve
questions and give you actually falsify
your view of your previous life which
often is rosecolored. So that was a
struggle but I think that gives a great
opportunity to begin to agonize about
things that you did that may have led
you on a particular course and that's
drawn out in the anxiety story because
you lucky you that you've reached your
age and you don't you didn't previously
agonize about I agonize all the time
about this. No, no, no. I can't say this
is the first time I've agonized about
it, right? But this this it it it made
me especially uncomfortable because you
do then go back and run back and the
choice you made like decision to spend
all the years in philosophy that I
spent. I mean I think about that
regularly
but think of all the thoughts on
compatibilism that you've had thanks to
your
That's right. It was a great benefit to
me. So any it's it's this this is the
sense why I see the collections
rebuilding because there a bunch of
building blocks that go in at various
stages in the collection and I don't
know if this was intentional but it a
lot of the stories seem building up to
the story and anxiety and the the the
idea of lifelocking is I think again
something that strikes me as a you know
Steve and I talk a lot about
technologies that are on the horizon u
we could hope they'll get to your New
York Times oped before we finish um but
genomic engineering of children uh we
think is coming very very soon and
lifelonging strikes me as something
that's here and going to become much
more common. I think about with my kids
my wife recently proposed that we
because you have these great events
little moments happen with your kids and
you just don't have a camera ready or
you pull up the camera and the kid
reacts differently. She wanted to buy a
little drone to basically have hover
around our kids capture things
constantly
or just mount it on the wall of your
house.
Yeah. But but you also want to get like
so they're traveling when the kids you
know you're there. Um and so like if
we're thinking about this now and it's
feasible and it's so attractive um it's
going to happen which means a lot of
implications about you will you'll be
able to resolve arguments as to what was
what happened before and this of course
is you know there's some extent exists
uh as Ted brings out in story through
simple writing of writing down what
happened but it's going to become much
more radical and it will in fact get at
uh so what I like about story is that
you brought in cognitive science about
the difference between episodic and
semantic memory and we actually add to
some extent records of sort of facts uh
through writing and to some extent
events, but this will bring in this will
radically change our experience of
episodic memory because it'll give us
much more kind of objective view of of
events. Um but it's just something that
that is going to really draw out the
ability to regret
actions that push you. So, I I I feel we
feel we should let Ted talk more, but I
can't resist saying that neuroscience
studies suggest that we only convert
about one bit of information per second
into long-term memory. So, basically
almost all of your past is lost to you.
And so, I've taken to just when I'm
traveling around just pulling out my
phone and just taking like 30 seconds of
video because it's still enormously more
information than I otherwise would have
about, you know, that moment visiting
San Francisco or whatever I was doing.
But most of the past is completely lost.
It's interesting. It's isly lost.
Although striking is it's often retained
in some vague form. So you see a
picture, you can of course it remind you
of something you can't actually
consciously recall
which is a good reason to be constantly
taking video and photos of your kids and
other stuff
or having a drone up above your head
or having a drone. Yeah, we need drones.
Anyway, Ted said, "Sorry, we've
discussion of your own work."
Yeah, I think it's it's going to be
debatable whether you actually will be
better off with the constant drone
footage of your kids because people say
that like people who who are recording
concerts that they go to, their own, you
know, their own recollection of the
concert is weaker because they were
recording it. And it may be that if
something similar happens with your
daily life, if you're recording your
daily life, then your own experiential
memory of your life may become weaker.
You will have the the digital footage.
But some would say that you you were
going to be poorer for for not
remembering it in an organic manner. So
I think there's going to be arguments
pro and con on this on this subject.
And you're going to spend half your life
like looking back at this more objective
version of your life you actually didn't
remember in the moment, right? It's a I
spend a lot of I'm very nostalgic, so I
spend a lot of time looking back at old
videos of my kids.
Yeah, I do too. I But I think the the
solution is um you outsource it. So your
experience at the concert, but the
little drone flying around is recording
it. And then the AI selects the parts of
it that are most pleasing to you or the
ones that are most likely to make you
stay on your diet or nice to your
neighbor. Whatever whatever impact you
want, the AI filters the memories and
shows you the ones that are likely to
have the desired outcome. So So that's
our future core. It's it's kind of kind
of a kept person phenomenon, right?
Well, hey, as long as I'm happy, as long
as I have the illusion of free will,
it's so it's everything's good.
Um, so well, I actually I I sort of
wonder like is that AI going to actually
choose the things that will make you
happier or will the AI choose to show
you the memories that will make Amazon
happier?
Yes, you you have to make sure someone
you trust wrote the code. Yeah, it's
it's gonna it's going to show you things
that will increase your purchases of
which you clearly can't do, right?
Yes. Yes.
I mean, I don't know what Google's
motivations are, but I have to say, you
know, there they
evil
perhaps you see the $1 billion
investment Microsoft made in Open AI.
I was open AI just a few days ago.
You know, it's clear and all I say is
whatever they're doing, right, these
little kind of herkyky jerky little
animations
just pull at your heartstrings, right?
It's almost their hokiness is something
that makes you just it's you know I just
have this well of emotion spring up when
I see my my kids kind of like in three
frames.
Absolutely. Yeah. There's no stronger
feeling in the you know I can watch a
little clip 10-second clip on my phone
of my kids when they were 10 or
something and it's like there's nothing
more uh engaging or stirring for me than
to actually see that. So um
you guys are familiar with the
experience machine, the nosic
experiment, thought experiment where you
can go in and like have you go into the
box and you have any possible experience
you want etc etc.
You can decide to live in the box.
Exactly. Yeah. And it turns out that men
have a much greater t inclination to
live in the box than women do. But but I
think you're really getting to a point
where you have a chance to relive your
past very very concretely perhaps even
with sort of more sensory experience.
and it's it's it's gonna be hard to
resist the sort of pleasant moments of
it especially as you get older.
Okay, let's get back on track because uh
we might be running low on time. Um so
one of the topics we wanted to discuss
was varieties of parallel universes and
let me just list two. One is where you
go to the parallel universe and the very
laws of physics are different like the
mass of the hydrogen atom or the proton
could be different in the other universe
or there's no electromagnetism in the
other universe and that that's actually
a potential possibility that string
theory suggests because there are
different vacuum states of string theory
in which the physical laws are
different. So that's one thing that
physicists have looked at recently. The
one that uh you actually I think
referenced in the story that you
mentioned where there's lots of envy is
I think the many worlds quantum
mechanics version of parallel universes
which by the way I do work on many
worlds quantum mechanics and I think
most people would be surprised to learn
that among theoretical physicists uh
particularly the ones who think about
cosmology and string theory and things
like that I think there are more many
worlds believers than there are not that
that many worlds might be close to the
majority opinion opinion at least among
certain subsets of physicists for the
right interpretation of quantum
mechanics and and so in many worlds
quantum mechanics every quantum event
that could go either way. So for example
I'm doing an experiment and I might
observe that the spin of this particle
is up or I might observe that the spin
of the particle is down rather than just
one of those outcomes being realized.
Actually both are realized but because I
see them in my conscious brain and it
causes a macroscopic rearrangement of my
memories two different branches of the
universe are created and can in a sense
no longer talk to each other or have
very minimal interference with each
other uh in which the different outcomes
are realized. So essentially all
possible outcomes are realized. There's
a Corey that uh went to law school
instead of uh business school instead of
philosophy grad school. And so these
different quories can wonder about each
other and be envious of each other
in the story anxiety is the diness of
freedom. It is based on the many worlds
interpretation and but I think with
regard to the sort of example that you
gave Steve it's important to note that
it is not so simple that uh of observing
like the spin state of a subatomic
particle leading to a person making one
decision or another. Some people have
argued that there is some kind of
quantum amplifier in our brains where
quantum uncertainty gives rise to neural
processes which may affect our
decision-m.
I personally uh am completely
unconvinced of that. I think that I mean
it's not impossible but I see no reason
to think that right now. I think that
any causal chain between some quantum
event and a human decision is going to
be much much longer and it will not be
the result of any quantum event that
actually took place within the particles
of your brain. It will be the result of
some quantum event elsewhere in the
earth's atmosphere which led to
different atmospheric conditions which
led to different slightly different
events in your life and then down the
line that may result in you actually
making a different decision.
Yes.
But it'll be quite a long causal chain
between the two.
Yes. What what you've described is the
conventional picture of how this all
works. There's a guy called Roger
Penrose and others who have advocated
that perhaps direct quantum mechanics is
quantum mechanics is directly related to
important functioning of your brain.
Almost nobody believes that actually. Um
the functioning of your brain seems to
be largely classical physics. And so the
way that this quantum indeterminism
would
amplify in order to influence your
decisions is through these much more
long much longer causal chains of events
involving lots of different particles
and different outcomes. Which is why I
think going back to our discussion of
free will, very few people think that
quantum mechanics has a particularly
large impact on the earlier purely
classical analysis of free will that we
discussed.
With regard to our brains, a huge gaping
hole in understanding is consciousness.
We virtually understand nothing about
consciousness. And so I think to, you
know, predetermine that it's not quantum
may be a little bit
ahead of schedule given that we actually
don't understand anything about the
phenomen.
No one's saying that uh they Yeah. No
one's saying they really fully
understand conscious. Just saying that
what appears to be like uh the important
actions in your brain like the firing of
a neuron that involves so many particles
and appears to not be coherent. uh
there's this technical term there uh
coherent in a quantum mechanical sense
that it's hard to imagine that uh it's
more than uh classical physics actually
that's determining the firing that
neuron. I actually found the argument
that to put it bluntly it's the it's the
weather dummy that matters right to be
fairly compelling your argument is I
take it is that there are these very
small quantum changes but they
effectively propagate through effects on
the weather small changes cause small
perturbations in ox in the collision of
oxygen atoms nitrogen atoms other things
in the atmosphere and these propagate
outward in very unpredictable ways and
just to take the example you give all
this you need is a very very subtle
effect on the human body to have an
effect on who's born in the next
generation.
Yes. But so first of all I agree with
your observation but there is weather in
your brain too right in the sense that
there are random fluctuations of stuff.
But I think to me the most sort of
accurate caricature of how this free
will argument should take place is that
because of quantum mechanics there is
perhaps some kind of almost true
randomness in the universe. Um, but if
you're a mostly classical robot living
in a universe where occasionally there
is randomness, like there are coin flips
happening outside of you, maybe
occasionally inside of you, that doesn't
mean that you have free will, right? It
means that you're still a mostly
classical robot living in a universe
with some random.
No, this was sort of an explanation as
to how you got these very very different
outcomes occurring by small
quantum perturbation.
Yes. And that is what in the many worlds
interpretation does allow for a universe
where Cory went to law school, Cory
became a professional football player.
It does allow for those things on some
of the branches to be realized.
Although I'm I'm just going to interject
that just because you are a classical
robot doesn't mean you don't have free
will because that's that's the whole
compatibilism argument.
Right. Right. I was just saying that it
doesn't change our earlier discussion.
The fact that there is quantum mechanics
probably doesn't change the nature of
our earlier discussion on compatibilism.
Yes. Yes. I agree. And it's also worth
pointing out that I think the desire to
attribute consciousness in some part to
quantum mechanics is maybe a reflection
of people's desire what what has some
sometimes been called the the
minimization of mystery that quantum
mechanics is mysterious and
consciousness is mysterious. And so
maybe these two mysterious things are
actually the same thing because that
would kind of reduce the amount of
mystery in the universe. But I don't
actually find that a compelling argument
for quantum mechanics playing a
significant role in consciousness.
Yeah, they're actually mysterious in
different ways.
Yeah, I Yeah, I think it seems very
implausible to me that quantum mechanics
plays an important role in
consciousness. Now the the other
direction the arrow in the other
direction has been advocated because the
person observing the spin of the
particle as it comes out of the detector
is a conscious person and so people have
posited that somehow quantum mechanics
depends on the interaction between the
spin of this little particle and the
consciousness observing it. That's the
sort of borian mysterian view that the
the consciousness collapses the wave
function of the electron. And that view
I think fewer and fewer physicists uh
are sympathetic to but at the time when
quantum mechanics was new there were a
lot of people who thought uh in that
way.
Yes. Yes. But yeah I I am also
unpersuaded about that.
Yeah I'm not either. I mean when you
just dig into the phenomena I don't want
to go a huge digression with conscious
but the phenomena you're having a hard
time explaining the consciousness is
just a very different phenomenon than a
kind of constrained randomness you have
in quantum mechanics. Right. They they
may be non-causal at least appear to be
non-causal in the same way but there's
not a sense of qualia qualitative
experiences you get with conscious
there's not a sense of a non-random
control under some sort of guidance you
have with consciousness none of that
appears in quantum mechanics so you're
kind of reducing one thing to something
that looks very unlike it that just
makes the reduction look impossible
one of the new pieces of information
we'll get in the next who knows few
decades maybe on this question is
whether you could evolve an AI which has
a sense of self and uh act you know self
maybe self-preservation action things
like this but which doesn't have qualia
so maybe qualia are just a side effect
of evolving an AI that needs to care for
itself and have some internal state or
thought about itself and you just then
get qualia as a side effect
question how would you know whether this
thing has qualia or not
well you could ask it hey do you feel
qualia yeah I'm really here I feel
don't turn me off don't touch that
switch
you couldn't tell of course whether you
evolved the tendency to say if qualia or
had qualia itself, right? You couldn't
tell the difference between gene,
right? You could it's self-report or
maybe you could measure something. But
uh anyway,
there is the argument that we rely on
self-report with other people and you
know we we we we think that's we think
that's that's sufficient. We believed
that other human beings had qualia uh
long before we had any you know fMRI
scanning equipment. So I think there is
an argument to be made that if a piece
of software's behavior was as rich and
varied as a human beings
that there'd be no good reason to doubt
its self-report any more than we have
any reason to doubt other pe people's
self-reported experiences.
Well Surl would disagree as you know. Uh
yes Surl would disagree. I think Surl is
completely completely wrong.
But maybe but his argument I think
merits consideration which is whether
it's actually the material that matters
whether it's the physical realization
rather than the behavior or the as
people like to say the functional
characterization that matters to
consciousness. And that's I'm a little
agnostic here because I can't tell you
to ever resolve this question. uh and
and SR's view we attribute consciousness
to other people in large part because
they're built of the same stuff that we
are but if you're built of something
take you know your story exhale right if
you're built of a kind of series of kind
of hydraulic a hydraulic system
involving gold plates uh very very thin
gold plates and small air canisters
I think it there's an incredible
emotional tendency much like our
emotional tendency to think we have free
will to attribute consciousness to such
a being I I'd say ultimately agnostic
about it because you can't prove one way
or the other whether this being as I
can't prove that you know Steve here is
conscious but you know he looks a lot
like me from the inside as far as I
could tell.
Yeah, but you can't prove that we aren't
living in a simulation and you guys are
all game characters and I'm the only
player character in the game, right?
We'll never be able to refute that.
Again, em an emotional intendency,
right? Which more or less is very
similar to free will. So I think these
are questions that are many ways it's
hard for me to figure out we're going to
go one way in free will and go another
way in these questions when they seem
ultimately based on the same kind of uh
weak evidential basis.
There is also the argument that the fact
that you are relying on, you know, sort
of a physical similarity between Steve
and you is a kind of, you know,
prejudice. You have a prejudiced against
beings which don't resemble you. And
that, you know, really you should judge
a conscious being by the content of
their character, not their physical
appearance. And if a conscious being its
behavior is as rich and varied as that
of another human being, it is perhaps
only prejudice which is preventing you
from granting it the same benefit of the
doubt that you grant other human beings.
Again, I'm I'm close to being agnostic
on this point. But but if we go down
this road, right,
the requiring their behaviors like mine
is also a form of prejudice. And so you
could take a position which is that
there's gradations of consciousness all
the way down to quirks and the more
complex behavior you exhibit the more
and more consciousness you have. So this
takes us to a kind of position that
Kristoff Caulk apparently is now
advocating which is consciousness goes
all the way down to the bottom the
smallest particles and that you simply
get higher levels of consciousness as
these begin to organize and exhibit more
complex behavior. So I think that's also
possible position and I can't see how
you would rule that out or rule out any
of the others. That's that's why I think
it's a you know that's where I think
that that I think is the argument for a
kind of strong agnosticism on
consciousness because it seems to be
driven by biases between positions you
actually can't come to any objective
conclusion about unless we have some
radical new physics allows essentially
to measure consciousness and maybe
that'll come at some point. current
physics doesn't allow it.
I think at some level you'll never
you'll never get past basic questions
like the simulation question. So no
matter how much our science advances, I
still won't be sure that I'm not in a
simulation that you guys could all be uh
game characters in the simulation.
So that's the key question. Will there
be a physics fundament at some point in
time where you can begin to measure
consciousness as a quantity?
Yeah, I doubt it.
But let me let let me switch gears
because we're running out of time. So,
we wanted to discuss Ted's
OpEd from the future that appeared in
the New York Times. And so, um, reading
from the New York Times, it says, "This
is the first installment in a new
series, OpEds from the future, in which
science fiction writers, futurists,
philosophers, and scientists write opeds
that they imagine we might read 10, 20,
or even 100red years in the future." And
Ted's op-ed was entitled, "It's 2059 and
the rich kids are still winning. DNA
tweaks won't fix our problems." And let
me just read the first sentence.
Last week, the Times published an
article about the long-term results of
the Gene Equality Project, the
philanthropic effort to bring genetic
cognitive enhancements to lowincome
communities. Sorry, read, I'll read the
second sentence as well. The results
were largely disappointing. While most
of the children born of the project have
now graduated from a 4-year college, few
attended elite universities, and even
fewer have found jobs with good salaries
or opportunities for advancement. So,
this envisions a future where genetic
cognitive enhancement is possible. It
actually works, but it doesn't fully
equalize class inequality. Um, I think
Ted because your implication is because
there are all kinds of environmental
benefits that the children of the rich
still have access to relative to the
poor, but I think in the in your oped
you were accepting the fact that one
could actually tweak cognitive ability
for the uh underclass and improve it. Is
is that fair? Well, I I I would phrase
it this way that in the piece I am
accepting the idea that it is possible
to identify genes and that are
associated with intelligence and to
engineer children to have, you know,
more of those genes. But I guess the the
thesis of the piece is that cognitive
gene enhancements or genetic cognitive
enhancements only provide a benefit if
you live in a meritocracy.
And if you don't live in a meritocracy
then they are not actually uh providing
a benefit and we don't live in a
meritocracy not I mean not a full
meritocracy. So the fact that people
desire genetic cognitive enhancements
for their children is a reflection of
their belief that we live in a
meritocracy.
Yes I understand.
And the fact that we don't I think is
something that may lead to some outcomes
that people are not expecting. This is
maybe an academic point, but in the
story though, the universe of the story,
the people who got the cognitive
advancements do, for example, read
better uh and do arithmetic or algebra
better than they would have had they not
gotten the genetic enhancements. In
other words, they did do something
biologically beneficial. Yeah. Okay.
It's just that society is still highly
unfair.
Yes. So as I understand your position,
Ted, I think you're you're not saying
that it's not it's completely not a
meritocracy. You're not saying it's a
full meritocracy. It's somewhere in
between. There's some statistical
contribution to success which is not
dependent upon your abilities and
dependent upon your privilege status and
that these kids do a little bit better
but not uh you know not as much as we
would like.
I'm just curious what what do you think
what do you think's missing? Is it the
connections? because you're really
coming to about today's society. Is the
connections? Is it the kind of soft
social skills? Is it um what is it you
think is non-mocratic about today's
society and likely continue to be
non-meritocratic?
Actually, I think most aspects of our
society are probably not meritocratic. I
think meritocracy only exists in very
narrow contexts in our society. I think
there is enormous systemic and
structural bias in our society and and
these things are going to be very very
difficult to correct and I think that
everyone likes to think that their
system is meritocratic. Everyone want
everyone wants to think that they're
choosing people based on their actual
skills their their actual performance.
But you know there is ample reason to
believe that you know that is not
actually the case in almost every aspect
of society. You know it's interesting
I've read two opeds in the past three or
four months. Uh one was yours and one
was a recent one in the time two opeds
in the times about uh a black female
professor at Yale who decided to ask
white guys about white privilege. I
think this ran just a couple days ago.
She describes different kinds of
experiences. Um, being in line in the
airport and having a bunch of, her
suggestion is basically a bunch of
people of color in line, women, and a
bunch of white guys showed up and they'd
have to basically stand behind this
group if they were to follow the rules,
but then they simply created their own
line right next to them and then were
merged into this existing line. So, half
of them went ahead of half of the people
in the original line. She eventually
works up the courage to ask one of these
guys uh after she had some pleasant
interactions with him about his white
privilege. And uh his response was that
I've earned everything that I've gotten.
I can't remember exactly what she said,
but my inclination was she should have
said, "How do you possibly know that?"
Uh-huh.
You know, how can you be aware of uh you
know, you sure that none of the friends
uh who helped you get jobs weren't
motivated by your skin color or your
parents' connections might not have
helped you in some particular way. It's
these kind of, you know, I tend to agree
with you there. These kind of things
that often hidden from us because we
have a hard time seeing or don't want to
see them that have enormous impact.
Everyone wants to believe that they
earned what they got. No matter how how
much privilege a person has, they are
going to say that they deserved what uh
everything that they got that they
worked for it. I think we can say did uh
did George W. Bush work for everything
he got? Or maybe did he benefit from the
fact that he had he came from a a
wealthy and powerful family? George W.
Bush would never say I got it easy. No,
George W. Bush is convinced that he
worked for everything he got. Everyone
is convinced of that, but that is
clearly not the case for everyone. I uh
I want to agree with you that luck plays
a huge role in most outcomes and it's
generally not acknowledged by people.
Now I at the risk of being uh too panic,
I want to just give a simple statistical
argument which should be familiar to
everyone but is not. So if imagine you
take a person who is exceptional in some
way. It could be that he's a very good
basketball player or it could be he's
very smart or he could very rich. Let's
suppose this person is four standard
deviations above average in terms of
whatever quality you're measuring for
him. The most likely to find a person
who is plus four standard deviations on
that quality is to find someone who's
plus two standard deviations in ability
and another plus two standard deviations
in luck. because both are playing a role
and uh it's much harder to get a plus
four fluctuation all in ability or all
in luck than to just combine two two
standard deviation fluctuations. So plus
two standard deviations is a couple of
percent probability but plus four is
like one in 30,000 or something like
this 50,000. So basically most people
who are above average have a component
of their success due to luck and a
component uh due to ability and same
thing for people with very bad outcomes.
they might be a little bit below average
on a characteristic but then they also
were unlucky conditional on just
selecting people that are super uh you
know who are in a super bad position in
life. So in almost all these cases there
is a hidden component of luck which just
from statistical analysis you can guess
is there in most situations but people
never acknowledge it because they're
just not used to thinking this way. So
sorry if that was too pedantic.
Now to come back to Ted's example, one
example people had given that may now be
forgotten is the contrast was often
drawn between George Bush and Roger
Clinton who was Clinton Bill Clinton's
half brother who had very very different
lives uh primarily because uh George
Bush came from wealthy family and Bill
Clinton came from a poor family and Bill
Clinton uh had some luck but he also had
extraordinary abilities that allowed him
to uh do well and uh George Bush did
well in spite of not particularly having
those skills.
But the reason I was particularly struck
by Ted's op-ed was not just because Ted
is one of my favorite science fiction
writers, but also that Times and other
people are starting to recognize this
idea that there is uh inequality in
genetic luck. That some people do get
more genetic luck than others. And that
maybe in the future we'll have
technologies that allow you to equalize
that genetic luck and then you might
even choose as a society to do that. Ted
is pointing out that even that is not
enough to have uh equality of outcome at
the end. But what struck me as very
interesting is a kind of flip-flop
between saying genes don't influence
anything, it's all environment to well
genes do inter uh affect some things and
so let's equalize that if we have the
technology now. So that seemed like a
big jump.
Well, I don't think the times I don't
think anyone's ever said genes don't
matter. I mean just look at like look
genes affect height, genes affects how
you look. Uh, you know, the Times may
have been skeptical about genes and
intelligence, but they were never
skeptical about genes and physical
appearance and power.
This article was about intelligence.
That's right. Okay. So, you're right. I
think that's becoming much more
mainstream. The the basic premise of TZ
accepting in this uh in this view. Now,
here's a question. It's kind of it's not
it's hidden in the back of your article,
but you don't think that having this
kind of engineering will equalize
things, but it's kind of unstated
whether you think it might be a good
idea for people to have the opportunity
to avail themselves of it if it does
improve outcomes in some degree. So, I'm
curious because, you know, you don't you
don't take a position on that, but you
must have thought about this as part of
writing the article or otherwise. Would
it be would it be good for society as a
whole?
Yeah,
it's not it's not clear to me that it's
it would be good for society as a whole.
Well, I think the article suggests that
it would very likely wind up being sort
of another excuse
used for inequality to justify
inequality. It would be a way for people
to claim that there's a biological basis
for the kind of class discrimination or
wealth discrimination that they already
engage in. So I I don't know that it
would be good for society as a whole.
On the other hand, as an outcome of this
uh genetic intervention, you have a lot
more people that are capable of doing a
good four-year college degree. So in
some absolute sense, don't you have a
more capable society than you did absent
uh these genetic interventions?
Maybe I suppose if my goal were to get
more people to graduate from four-year
college, you know, I think, you know, my
preferred route would be entirely
different. It would be thing things
things like free college for everyone
which has has been proposed and is
something that you know a lot of people
argue would not be that expensive
compared to some of the other things
that we spend money on and you know I
think that would be I think that would
be a much better way of getting more
people to complete a four-year degree.
My concern with both of these proposals
is actually I think they would probably
end up exaggerating inequality
given that people are more likely to
avail themselves of uh genetic engineer
opportunities are likely to be wealthy.
And if we keep the current cost
structure of college the same and we
allow people to go free to places like
Yale and Harvard, uh you already may be
favoring people more likely to get into
those schools in the first place by
having them not have to pay. So we have
to like change the I'm very sympathetic
to the free college idea, but we have to
change the structure of college costs.
So you're not simply subsidizing people
going to wealthy people going to wealthy
colleges. I think some of the debt I
don't get long some of the debt
forgiveness proposals are going to wipe
out debt for people who are often fairly
wealthy.
That's that's true that you we would
have to have a long conversation about
the the best way to sort of uh eliminate
college debt or make college accessible
to the largest number of people. I
believe that the cost of free IVF and
free crisper is way below the cost of
the college education four years of
college education for one individual.
It's probably about a quarter uh of the
cost. So just throw just throwing that
out there. But but free IVF or crisper
to do what exactly? Right. Presumably
there hundreds of genes intelligence you
actually don't know the effects you
change these genes as we seem with the
current case. So, you know, we're not
anywhere close to
No, I meant I meant in his this his is
science fiction. So, this is set in
2059. So, assuming Crisper gets better,
gene mapping gets better, cost of an IVF
cycle might be $10,000, cost of the
crisper vector might be $20. It's a lot
less than four years of tuition at
Michigan State or Harvard.
Well, then there's the question of what
is the goal? Is your goal to sort of
increase the number of of smart people
as cheaply as possible or is your goal
to uh sort of create a more just
society?
If if if your goal is like how do we
create more smart people as cheaply as
possible, then yes, like there are
probably all sorts of ways that we could
do that. If your goal is to create a
more just society, then I don't I don't
I don't think genetic cognitive
enhancements do you play a role in that.
Not not or a very only a very small
role.
I think it'll have the opposite effect
actually.
Well, I think these technologies will at
least in the short run have the opposite
effect. It'll they'll increase uh
inequality rather than decrease it. The
the question is sort of theoretically in
the long run if you have a you know
wonderful Scandinavian style government
that's progressive and quasy socialistic
could they use the genetic technologies
to good end and it's not clear to me
whether that that's the case but it's
not excluded
a Scandinavian style world government
right
yeah world government
okay yeah the the federation
all right well we're way over time Ted
so I I really appreciate you're spending
this much time with us. I I really
enjoyed the discussion. I'm sorry we
didn't let you talk more. Cory and I got
too excited about the topics, but uh
it's been great and uh we will edit this
into something intelligible, I hope, and
I think the fans will really enjoy it.
This has really been a pleasure, Ted.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me. I I I enjoyed I
enjoyed the conversation.